This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例只有这么点。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中培养韧性的秘诀。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加百分号，在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。还有我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不太安全，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副重甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力，就非得这么做。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，在这里我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化与转折，以及它们对我们心理学意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. today we are here to talk about our families, to talk about parents and family dynamics and how they change in our 20s, or more specifically, I think, how they really begin to reveal themselves to us as we further enter this decade. For many of us, you know, family is supposed to be the source of unconditional love and loyalty and support, and it's meant to be a safe haven. But what happens when that doesn't really match up with our experience. And why is it that so many of us in our 20s really start questioning the role our families play in our lives and begin to unpack how they've
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你们能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们今天要剖析的是二十多岁的心理学。今天我们在这里谈论我们的家庭，谈论父母和家庭动态，以及它们在我们二十多岁时是如何改变的，或者更具体地说，我认为，随着我们更深入地进入这个十年，它们是如何真正开始向我们显露真容的。对我们许多人来说，你知道，家庭本该是无条件爱、忠诚和支持的源泉，它应该是一个避风港。但当现实与我们的经历不符时，会发生什么呢？为什么我们当中有这么多人，在二十多岁时真的开始质疑家庭在我们生活中扮演的角色，并开始剖析他们是如何
shaped us for better or for worse and how they will continue to shape us? So I really want to explore some of those common struggles that come with having a family and having strange, complicated parental dynamics and the nuances of it all. You know, I can. think it's really interesting that it's not black and white. It's not that you are that completely hate your family. You want to be estranged from them or you have to completely love them. A lot of us exist in the gray space in the middle. So why is that the case? How do we navigate, having complicated feelings towards family? And of course, I wanted to bring on an amazing guest who was an expert on this to help us rethink healthy boundaries, family expectations, all of the above. These are very
塑造了我们——无论好坏——以及他们将如何继续塑造我们？所以我真的很想探讨一些伴随着组建家庭、拥有紧张复杂的父母关系以及其中所有微妙之处而产生的常见挣扎。你知道，我觉得这很有趣，它不是非黑即白的。不是说你完全恨你的家人。你想要与他们疏远，或者你必须完全爱他们。我们许多人都生活在中间的灰色地带。那么为什么会这样呢？我们该如何应对对家庭的复杂情感？当然，我想要邀请一位对此颇有研究的优秀嘉宾来帮助我们重新思考健康的边界、家庭期望以及所有这些方面。这些都是非常
big, heavy topics, but they are so necessary. So I want to welcome on Gwendolyn Watson. Gwendolyn, how are you doing? Hi. Thank you so much for having me. I'm doing great. This was the highlight of my day. I was looking forward to this. Oh my gosh. Thank you. That always makes me feel very, very happy. Just a little compliment to begin the episode. None of the listeners have probably met you before. Maybe they have. So can you tell us a little bit about your and how exactly you became, will a marriage and family therapist, above all else? Yeah, definitely. Yeah, I love reflecting on my journey to become a therapist because it's so aligned with
宏大且沉重的话题，但它们又是如此必要。所以我想欢迎格温多琳·沃森。格温多琳，你好吗？嗨。非常感谢邀请我来。我很好。这是我今天最开心的时刻。我一直很期待这个。天哪。谢谢。这总是让我感到非常非常开心。作为节目的开场，先给你一个小小的赞美。听众们大概都还没见过你。也许见过。所以你能给我们介绍一下你的背景，以及你究竟是怎么成为一名婚姻和家庭治疗师的吗？好问题，绝对可以。是的，我很喜欢回顾我成为治疗师的历程，因为它与
some of the themes that we're going to explore as well. So, you know, grew up in a family that had a lot of dynamics. I was one of four kids. My mom, abstract painter, poet, you know, kind of very expansive woman from England. And I grew up in America, and my dad was a tax lawyer from the South. So just already, like, How did that happen? That's a whole other podcast of how they met. Oh, my goodness. Yeah, just growing up in that environment of a lot of different perspectives on values and life. And as a middle child, as I'm sure you've explored in past episodes, a lot of my development was around really noticing how,
我们要探讨的一些主题非常契合。所以，你知道的，我在一个动态关系很多的家庭中长大。我是四个孩子中的老大...噢不，四个孩子之一。我妈妈是抽象派画家、诗人，你知道的，是一个来自英国、性格非常豁达的女性。我在美国长大，我爸爸是来自南方的税务律师。所以仅凭这一点，就像，这怎么可能发生？关于他们是怎么认识的，那是另一个播客的故事了。哦，天哪。是的，在那种充满对价值观和生活有许多不同看法的环境中长大。作为一个中间的孩子，正如你一定在过去的节目中探讨过的，我的许多成长都围绕着真正注意到如何...
to have certain reactions from people, noticing what brought about a sense of joy, a sense of acceptance, and maybe what things would bring about a sense of anxiety from my parents. Part of that experience also, I'm an identical twin. Oh, my goodness. I know. Oh, my God, you're a middle child and an identical twin, so you didn't even get to just be the only middle child. Exactly.
从人们那里得到某些反应，注意到是什么带来了快乐感、接纳感，以及也许是什么会给我的父母带来焦虑感。那段经历的一部分也是，我是个同卵双胞胎。哦，天哪。我知道。天哪，你是个中间孩子，还是同卵双胞胎，所以你甚至连仅仅做一个中间孩子的机会都没有。完全正确。
To do it with someone else who was identical. Oh, my goodness, gracious. Yes. So my journey into my 20s, I felt like it was one of those first times of asking myself, you know, like, how do I feel about something? What do I want? I studied art history and then jumped from that and went into Google, worked in business development for almost a decade. And yet I found myself walking through the corridors, like walking through the cubicles, kind of keeping that feeling of disconnection at bay. I remember one time I walked into an
而是要和另一个长得一模一样的人一起做这件事。天哪，天哪。是的。所以在我进入二十多岁的旅程中，我觉得这是第一次问自己，你知道的，比如：对于某件事我是怎么想的？我想要什么？我学的是艺术史，然后从艺术史转行去了谷歌，在商业发展部门工作了近十年。然而我却发现自己走在走廊里，就像走在格子间里一样，试图把那种与世隔绝的感觉挡在门外。我记得有一次我走进一个
empty conference room and found myself tearful and not knowing why. And it really was that, like I was starting to get in touch with this feeling of, this isn't what I want my life to be. That process kind of got in touch with the fact that my whole life I've been serving some type of helping profession role. And I've always been. really curious about relationships. I was a young kid curious about my parents' relationship. I was a young kid like trying to negotiate friendship struggles on the playground. And I was like a very highly sensitive, attuned, emotionally attuned kid and teen and young adult. So started to think about, I think being a therapist is actually more aligned with what I want.
空会议室里，发现自己无缘无故地流泪了。那种感觉真的就像是，我开始接触到这样一种感觉：这不是我想要的生活。那个过程让我开始面对这样一个事实：我的一生一直在扮演某种助人类的角色。而且我一直对人际关系充满好奇。我很小的时候就对父母的关系感到好奇。我很小的时候就在游乐场上试图解决友谊方面的纠纷。我是一个高度敏感、善解人意、情感敏锐的孩子、青少年和年轻成人。所以开始思考，我觉得当一名治疗师其实更符合我的心意。
And I remember calling my parents to share with them that I was embarking on this new journey. And in that moment, you know, I was really ready for them to like be on the same page with me. And of course, as it happens, they were in shock. They had a lot of anxiety. You know, they had a lot of their own stories of raising kids with, you know, some like professional uncertainty. my dad my dad's firm who's working for like collapsed and he had a mortgage with three kids at the time there's just like these own stories of their own experiences around sudden career change that were coming up and was like why would you like what like you're but you have so much stability like and you're so good at it like not
我记得我打电话给父母，跟他们分享我要踏上这个新旅程的消息。当时，你知道的，我真的做好了准备让他们能和我站在同一阵线上。当然，正如俗话所说，他们震惊了。他们感到非常焦虑。你知道的，他们有自己抚养孩子的故事，其中包含着一些职业上的不确定性。我爸爸，我爸爸工作的公司破产了，当时他背着房贷，还有三个孩子要养。他们的脑海里浮现出自己对突发职业变动的经历，然后就会问：你为什么要这样做？你有什么想不开的？你看你有多稳定，而且你干得那么好，没有
there's no signs that you should change your career. And in that conversation, you know, from their own anxiety, they, you know, they said they had strong reactions. And it was quite hurtful for me at the time. You know, now we've moved through it and I can see the two sides of the story. But in that moment, you know, I just was shocked that something that felt so beautiful to me was landing for them as so scary, such a bad idea, definitely not what I should be doing. And, you know, like giving up, that I was really losing and giving up as opposed to opening and gaining like a new chapter. So it was one of those moments where I had to be at peace with, even though they're not on board, I'm on board. Like, I'm on board with myself. And I can give them space.
任何迹象表明你应该转行。在那个对话中，你知道，出于他们自身的焦虑，他们，你知道的，做出了强烈的反应。当时这对我来说挺伤人的。你知道，现在我们已经走出来了，我能看到事情的两个方面。但在那个时刻，你知道，我只是感到震惊，一件对我觉得那么美好的事情，在他们听来却那么可怕、是个极其糟糕的主意、绝对是我不应该做的事。而且，你知道的，就好像我在放弃，我是在失去和放弃，而不是在开启和获得一个新篇章。所以那是那种我必须学着内心平静的时刻之一：即使他们不支持我，我也支持我自己。我是支持我自己的。我可以给他们时间
to come around. Like, if this is true, if I'm really becoming a therapist not to please them or to please anyone else, if this is really my vocation, then I believe in myself to put in the work to make it happen. So yeah, that was a long, long-winded answer, but now I'm in private practice now. I've had a couple different experiences as a therapist with different populations. And I get to work with adults and couples and families and support them in the navigation of relationships, which are, as you said in your intro, so nuanced, so complex. And really, I think, the best catalyst for growth for all of us as human beings. That's a really beautiful story. And I think that it ties really perfectly in with what we're talking about today, which is doing what's best for you versus what your family
去转变观念。如果这是真的，如果我成为治疗师不是为了取悦他们或取悦任何人，如果这真的是我的天职，那么我相信自己有能力付出努力去实现它。所以，是的，那是长篇大论的回答，但现在我有了自己的私人诊所。作为一名治疗师，我在不同的群体中有过几种不同的经历。我有机会与成年人、情侣和家庭合作，支持他们应对人际关系，正如你在开场所说的那样，这些关系是如此微妙、如此复杂。而且它们确实是全人类成长最好的催化剂。这真的是一个很美妙的故事。而且我觉得它与我们今天讨论的话题完美契合，那就是做对自己最好的事，而不是你家人
thinks is best for you having not so much conflict, but different opinions. in families, disappointing your parents. But speaking of family, why do you think so many of us start really questioning the reality or what family should look like in our 20s? What is it about our 20s that really makes us start reconsidering how we were raised, how we grew up, and maybe some of the resentment around that as well? Yeah. Yeah. I mean, again, this is assuming that you lived with your family of origin the whole time and then kind of left home in your 20s, which I know isn't the case for everyone. But assuming that progression, it can be, you know, when you're living in an environment, the ability to question what's happening, there isn't always space for that. That takes a pretty
认为对你最好的事，这其中与其说是冲突，不如说是不同的观点。在家庭中，这关乎让父母失望。但说到家庭，你认为为什么我们当中有这么多人开始在二十多岁时真正质疑现实或者家庭本该是什么样子？究竟是什么让我们在二十多岁时开始重新审视我们的抚养方式、成长经历，以及随之而来的一些怨恨情绪？是的。我的意思是，当然，这假设你一直和原生家庭住在一起，然后到二十多岁才离开家，我知道这并不适用于所有人。但假设有这样一个发展过程，你知道，当你身处一个环境中时，质疑正在发生的事情的能力，并不总是存在的。那需要一个相当
like secure and strong and safe environment to be able to outwardly name and question certain patterns or certain behaviors or certain values that are happening within a family system. So in your 20s, once you're left home, there's literally the oxygen to pause and say, hold on a second, like, what are the values that really aligned for me? Right. And sometimes, there's this beautiful quote that I love from, for act therapy, which is acceptance and commitment therapy, which says, in our pain, we find our values. And in our, values we find our pain. And I think a lot of being in your 20s is that invitation where you have the space, you often have the time to pause and say, what did I experience that did have pain,
安全、坚固且稳定的环境，才能公开指出并质疑家庭系统内部存在的某些模式、某些行为或某些价值观。所以在你二十多岁时，一旦你离开家，你才真正有了空间去暂停并说：等一下，对我来说真正契合的价值观到底是什么？没错。有时候，我非常喜欢接纳承诺疗法（ACT）中的一句名言，它说：我们在痛苦中寻找我们的价值观。而在我们的价值观中，我们找到了痛苦。我认为二十多岁的很大一部分体验就是那种邀请，让你有空间、通常也有时间去暂停，然后问：我经历了什么确实带来痛苦的事情，
that maybe at the time I minimized or, you know, kind of brushed away or repressed or just didn't even notice, just thought it was just kind of normal. What did I experience that had some pain connected to it and what does that tell me about what I really care about. Some of our values are adopted and kind of carried forth down the generation from our families of origin and down the generations. And some of them are in reaction to or kind of like a renewed value that is in contrast to values that we were raised with. So, you know, I'm going on a little bit of a tangent myself, but I think that in your 20s, there's actually that space to pause and to reflect. And something that I also love thinking about for folks in their 20s, we talk a lot about,
可能当时我将其淡化了，或者，你知道的，将其挥之不去、压抑下去，或者甚至没有注意到，只是觉得它很正常？我经历了什么与痛苦相关的事情，这向我揭示了我真正关心的是什么？我们的一些价值观是从原生家庭代代相传下来的。而另一些价值观则是对我们成长环境中价值观的一种反叛，或者说是一种焕然一新的价值观，与我们从小接受的价值观形成鲜明对比。所以，你知道的，我自己也有点扯远了，但我认为在你二十多岁时，确实有那个空间去暂停并进行反思。对于处于二十多岁的人，我也很喜欢思考一件事，我们经常讨论
you know, you've probably heard a lot on social media and just if you're in your own therapy, your inner child. And I love introducing the concept alongside your inner child of your inner team, who's like a freaking badass. wants to question things and wants to, you know, like kind of like isn't afraid to maybe disrupt the status quo or to push back about things. And your 20s is kind of the first time when you get to integrate your inner team because you're not, you know, you're not living your teen years. You're able to kind of feel into that, that team side that hold on a second side, right? They're like, what do I care about? When do I want to speak up side?
你可能在社交媒体上听过很多次，如果你在做心理咨询的话，也会听到“内在小孩”。而我喜欢引入另一个与“内在小孩”并存的概念，那就是你的“内在团队”，这个团队简直酷毙了。它想要质疑事物，想要，你知道的，某种程度上不怕去打破现状，或者对事物进行回击。而你的二十多岁其实是你第一次能够整合你的内在团队的时候，因为你不是，你知道的，你不再过着你的青少年时期。你能够去感受那种团队的那一面，“等一下”的那一面，对吧？他们会说：我关心的是什么？我什么时候想大声说出来？
but that it's not kind of ruling the ship the same way that, you know, that you're living that in your teens, but you're also dealing with all the things you're dealing with in your teens. So your 20s, there's a way to kind of feel into that and kind of integrate like what part of me is in touch with my values. And maybe what part of me is a little bit of my inner teen, like just wanting to have fun or wanting to make mistakes or wanting to do something off the cuff and spontaneous and against what people expect of me. And so yeah, I think the 20s, it's a beautiful, beautiful time that there's so much space for all of that. But it is, it's a really unique time to, you know, I say it's kind of like you're giving birth to yourself, that you're allowing yourself
但它又不像你处于青少年时期那样统治着你的生活，那时候你要应对青少年时期需要处理的所有事情。所以在你的二十多岁，有一种方法可以去感受那种状态，并整合我身上哪一部分与我的价值观保持一致。也许我身上的哪一部分有点像我的内在小孩，只是想找点乐子，或者想犯点错误，或者想做一些随性、冲动且违背人们对我的期望的事情。所以，是的，我认为二十多岁是一个极其美妙的时期，有如此多的空间去容纳这一切。但它确实是一个非常独特的时期，你知道的，我说这就有点像你在孕育你自己，你允许自己
to come into your adulthood. Yeah. And I feel like, wow, that's all coming up and you're having what is a really huge transformation into adulthood. Yes, you have the oxygen to look at your family differently. Like you have the breathing room. And you also start to talk to other people about their experiences as well. And I think become a bit more independently educated about what may have benefited you more, what family dynamics maybe should have looked like. And with that, that can bring up.
进入成年期。是的。我觉得，哇，所有这些情绪都涌上心头，你正在经历向成年期真正巨大的转变。没错，你有呼吸的空间去以不同的方式看待你的家庭。就像你有了喘息的空间。而且你也会开始和别人谈论他们的经历。我想，你会对什么对你更有利、家庭动态本来应该是什么样子有更独立的认识。随之而来的，也会带来
the resentment as well of why didn't I have the childhood like that? Was that not meant to, was I actually not meant to be treated that way? And a big question which we, which you talked about before is the push towards individualization. And I think a big question around becoming an individual is how would I do that differently? You know, my parents set an example, but as an individual, how would I have done that differently and how will I do it differently in my own life with my friends, with my kids, with my family. And sometimes that brings up some heavy stuff. When you begin to really realize the ways you've perhaps maybe been let down, hurt by your parents or family, maybe disappointed in the past, what kind of reactions do you
怨恨情绪：为什么我没有那样的童年？我难道不应该，我其实不应该受到那种对待吗？一个我们之前讨论过的大问题是向个体内化的推动。我认为围绕成为一个独立个体的一个大问题是：我会如何以不同的方式做到这一点？你知道的，我的父母树立了榜样，但作为一个个体，我会如何以不同的方式做到这一点，以及我将如何在自己的生活中与朋友、孩子、家人以不同的方式做到这一点？有时这会带来一些沉重的东西。当你开始真正意识到自己可能曾被父母或家庭失望、伤害，或者过去可能曾感到失望时，你觉得人们往往会有什么样
think people tend to have? Because it's a very hard realization. I think whether you have it as a teenager or as in your 20s, be like, oh, my family is it perfect and I'm just going to have to live with that. What are some of the reactions we initially tend to have towards that realization? Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think you named it with that experience of, it's kind of an experience of grief and of loss, like a loss of what you wished you had had. And with grief, with any type of processing loss, like the reactions really run the gamut, right? Like that it is so individual for some people, it might be that feeling of, you know, a feeling of anger or of irritation or of sadness.
的反应？因为这是一个很难接受的认识。我想不管你是在十几岁时还是在二十多岁时意识到这一点，都会想：哦，我的家庭并不完美，我只能接受现实。面对这种认识，我们最初往往会有哪些反应？是的。我的意思是，我想你用那段经历说出来了，这其实是一种悲伤和失落的体验，是对你所希望拥有的东西的一种失落。而对于悲伤，对于任何类型的处理失落的过程，反应真的是五花八门，对吧？它对每个人来说都是如此独特，对某些人来说，可能是那种感觉，
You know, I do a lot with parts work. So kind of thinking about the different parts of yourself. And I think when you're talking about integrating a story of what happened in my past and how do I feel about it, my approach is always to make space for all the different parts of you and how all the different parts of you might feel, right? There might be kind of an intellectual, wise part that says, you know, well, like, this is the way that I'm going to, you know, think about it. Like, clearly X, Y, Z happened and it kind of uses. intellectualization to find a narrative. And there might be that, you know, that inner, you know, maybe boundaryed or angry part that really just wants to be in touch with anger and be in touch with like, that wasn't fair. Sometimes that anger part is connected to a sense of justice. Like,
一种愤怒、恼怒或悲伤的感觉。你知道的，我做了很多关于“人格部分工作”的事情。也就是思考你不同的内在部分。我认为当你谈论整合过去发生的事情的故事以及我对它的感受时，我的方法总是为你的所有不同部分留出空间，以及你所有的不同部分可能会有什么样的感受，对吧？可能会有一个理智、明智的部分说，你知道的，好吧，这就是我要，你知道的，思考它的方式。显然发生了X、Y、Z，然后它有点利用。理智化来寻找一个叙事。也可能会有那个，你知道的，内在的，
it shouldn't have been that way. And there's often a young part that is in touch with fear or yeah just you know fear or shut down or just quite quiet you know sitting in the quietness of of an experience and so you know i get i get this question from clients sometimes like am i supposed to feel this or how should i feel and i always want to invite you know actually there are so many parts of you that are experiencing this processing of what family means or what happened that I wish hadn't happened. So how can we actually make space for all of those parts of you? And notice if one part and one side of you is really holding the microphone, no pun intended as we hold our microphones, if one side of you is really speaking quite loud,
也许带有边界的、愤怒的部分，它真的只想接触愤怒，只想接触“这不公平”的感觉。有时那个愤怒的部分与正义感有关。就像，事情本不该是这样的。通常还有一个年轻的部分，它接触到的是恐惧，或者，是的，只是恐惧、封闭，或者相当安静，你知道，坐在经历的安静之中。所以，你知道，我有时会从客户那里得到这个问题：我是不是应该有这种感觉？或者我应该有什么感觉？我总是想邀请大家，其实你的许多不同部分都在经历这种处理过程：家庭意味着什么，或者发生了什么我希望没有发生的事。所以我们究竟该如何为你的所有这些部分腾出空间？并注意如果某一部分和你的某一侧真的在拿着麦克风——正如我们拿着麦克风一样，双关语——如果你的某一侧真的声音很大，
let's give it that space, let's let it air out how it felt, but let's also notice the other sides of you that maybe have something to say as well. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, go ahead. Oh, no, I was just going to say, like, I think anger and grief are like the two big ones. And like anger and grief are the two big ones that are very hard to process. And I've often found that if you just ignore them and you say to yourself, I have no right to be angry or I need to, put away this anger and just pretend like everything is normal and that's very relevant, especially around the holidays when we're recording this. That does not make it better and that does not make it more bearable because you're still minimizing. You're still minimizing for other people,
我们就给它这个空间，让它宣泄它的感受，但我们也要注意你身上可能还有话要说的其他部分。是的，绝对的。是的，你接着说。哦，不，我只是想说，像愤怒和悲伤是两个主要的情绪。愤怒和悲伤是两个很难处理的主要情绪。我经常发现，如果你只是忽视它们，对自己说“我没有权利生气”或者“我需要放下这种愤怒，假装一切正常”，这种做法在节假日期间尤其普遍——我们正是在这个时候录制节目的。这并不会让情况变好，也不会让事情变得更容易忍受，因为你仍在轻描淡写。你仍在为别人轻描淡写，
right? Any like emotional reaction you're having to being disappointed by your family or disappointing your family is a reaction that I think needs to have, has a full life cycle, right? There's a birth of it normally like when you are a child or when you're a teenager. Then there is the life of it when you're really, really feeling that emotion. And eventually the emotion might die or it might become a bit weaker, a bit more fragile. Sometimes that does take time. But also you can't put it into a box and expect that it's not going to want to break out.
对吧？你对被家人失望或让家人失望所产生的任何情感反应，都是一种我认为需要经历完整生命周期的反应，对吧？它通常有一个诞生期，比如当你还是个孩子或青少年的时候。然后是它的生存期，当你真切、真切地感受到那种情绪的时候。最终这种情绪可能会消亡，或者可能会变得有点虚弱、有点脆弱。有时这确实需要时间。但同时，你也不能把它关进盒子里，指望它不会想要破门而出。
So I really like what you're saying. Like you need to give space for every single reaction that you're feeling. towards your nuanced family dynamics. When it's the case that you still have to be, you know, be present with your family. You obviously don't, you might not want to cut them off. You know, especially around the holidays, there's a big conversation of people being like,
所以我真的很喜欢你所说的：你需要为你对微妙的家庭动态所感受到的每一个反应留出空间。当出现你仍然必须陪伴家人的情况时，你显然不会，你可能不想和他们断绝关系。你知道，尤其是在节假日期间，有一个很大的讨论，人们会说：
I have to go, I'm going home for Christmas and I just know that this stuff is going to come up. I'm predicting that like I'm probably going to fall back into old patterns with my family. how do you navigate that? How do you make sure that you're still looking forward and looking to heal whilst perhaps back in the same environment that caused you the pain in the first place? Yeah, yeah.
我必须去，我要回家过圣诞节，而我明知这些事情会浮现。我预料到我可能会重新陷入与家人相处的旧模式中。你该如何应对？你如何确保自己一方面在向前看、寻求治愈，同时又身处最初给你带来痛苦的同一个环境中？是的，是的。
I mean, I guess I want to name that even the word family means so many different things for so many different people, right? And that although there is a quite common experience of when we're back with our families of origin, we suddenly find ourselves. like feeling 15 again or feeling quite young. Like, you know, and I mean, even me, like, peaking at 40, like, the same thing happens to me. Like, Thanksgiving, I was like, God, I just, I really just feel like a 15-year-old again. So, like, that felt experience is, is psychologically normal. I don't know what else to phrase it? Like, it's a shared experience
我的意思是，我想指出的是，甚至“家庭”这个词对许多不同的人来说也意味着许多不同的事情，对吧？虽然有一个非常普遍的经验：当我们回到原生家庭时，我们会突然发现自己...
that a lot of people have. And, you know, going home to family, there is it's such a spectrum. So I want to, I want to, I guess I want to offer empathy to folks who are listening to this conversation that for some people, you might be going back to family where, you know, there are, we don't get to choose who our parents are. You know, it is possible that you have parents that, for their own reasons and their own things that they're struggling with, have consistent and characterological ways of dismissing or hurting you physically or psychologically. And there's other people who going back to family, you know, they're going back to parents who are trying their best and still disappointing, right? That might be showing love through their, like, only know how to show
就像又回到了15岁，或者感觉自己还很年轻。你知道的，我的意思是，甚至连我，快40岁了，同样的事情也会发生在我身上。感恩节的时候，我就想：天哪，我只是，我真的觉得自己又像个15岁的孩子了。所以，那种亲身体验在心理上是正常的。我不知道该怎么用别的词来表达？就像这是一种很多人都有的共同体验。而且，回家面对家人，这真的是一个光谱。所以我想，我想，我想向收听这段对话的人表达同情：对某些人来说，你可能要回到这样一个家庭，在那里，你知道的，我们没得选择谁是我们的父母。你知道，你很有可能有这样的父母：由于他们自身的原因和他们正在挣扎的事情，他们有着一贯的、性格化的方式去贬低你，或者在身体上或心理上伤害你。还有另一些人，他们回家，你知道的，他们是回到那些尽力了却依然让人失望的父母身边，对吧？他们可能会通过他们的...方式表达爱意，比如他们只知道如何通过焦虑来表达爱，或者只知道如何通过批评来表达爱。他们说爱你可能是出于真心，但实际上，他们在对你说：你为什么穿成这样参加圣诞晚会？就像，真的吗？你的工作怎么回事？你怎么还没赚到更多钱？你还没...
loves through anxiety or only know how to show love through criticizing. And it's intentional to say, that they love you, but in actuality, like, they're telling you, why are you wearing that to Christmas dinner? And it's like, really? Like, what's happening with your job? Like, why do you make more money? Have you not yet? Yeah, yeah. I can't believe you broke up with that person. They were the only person who cared about you, you know? Like, there's so, I'm wanting to normalize the spectrum, right? And, and say that, um, although there's a common experience of going home from the holidays, like, you know, your truth. You know, like, am I dealing? with a family that's rough around the edges and imperfect in the way that humans are imperfect?
天哪，真不敢相信你和那个人分手了。他们是唯一真正在乎你的人，你知道的。所以，有太多...我希望将这个光谱正常化，对吧？并指出，虽然回家过节是一种普遍体验，但你清楚自己的真相。你知道的，我是不是在和一个外表粗糙、带有普通人类不完美性的家庭打交道？还是说我在一个这样的环境中长大：当我回家时，我真的必须格外小心，注意如何去处理安全感和应对当下的时刻？当然，有些人如果确实回到了他们目睹过长期受辱、被贬低或真正感受到那种蓄意的权力和控制的家庭，他们可能就不会回家过节了。他们可能会去寻找自己选择的朋友和自己选择的家庭来一起过节。但我想对我的客户说的是：停下来想一想，你想要什么？你
Or did I grow up in an environment where when I return home, I really have to be cautious around what it means to navigate safety and navigate this moment? Of course, some people, by that, if they really are returning to homes where they've seen a long enough pattern of, you know, whether it's humiliation or being put down or really just feeling that like intentionality of power and control, they might not be going home for the holidays. They might be finding chosen friends and chosen family to be engaging in the holidays with. But I guess what I offer to my clients is pausing to think about what do you want and what What do you need?
需要什么？对我来说，每当我回家过节、有些事情又相当敏感的时候。那种感觉就像是肚子朝上的那种软肋感，是的，就像软肋受到攻击的那种敏感。我不知道这个比喻是否说得通。但我可能会说，我需要的是不讨论那些我知道的、肯定会让我感到需要高度保护的事情，你知道的。所以我提前有了这种觉悟。如果有人提起或者问我这件事，你知道的，我会以友善的态度回应，但会说：谢谢关心，我今天还没准备好谈这个，或者，今天我没有心思聊这个。所以我提前做好了准备：为了我自己的内心和灵魂，我需要什么样的边界？为了我自己的身体，我又需要什么？
For me, whenever there's times when I'm going home for the holidays and there's certain things that are quite sensitive. Like it feels kind of like soft belly type of, yeah, like a soft belly up sensitivity. I don't know if that metaphor makes sense. But I might say that what I need is to not discuss the certain things that I know, like, are quite, that I'm quite protective around, you know. So I have that awareness in advance. and if people are bringing it up or asking me about that, you know, I'll kind of respond with
你知道，就我个人而言，我在节假日期间不能喝酒，因为我是个情感相当开放的人。如果我在家人面前喝了哪怕半杯酒，而他们随后说了一句他们本意是好意、但在我听来却是批评的话，我会更容易情绪崩溃。所以我也在考虑我自己的身体。为了我自己的身体，有哪些是我不能妥协的？除此之外就是想要的了。比如，我过节想要什么？
kindness, but just say, like, thanks for asking. I'm not ready to talk about that or, you know, today, and I don't have the space to talk about that today. So I kind of have in advance, I've kind of prepared, like, what do I need for my own heart and soul to have that boundary? And what do I also need for my own body? You know, for me personally, I can't drink alcohol around the holidays because I am a quite emotionally open person. And if I have even half of a drink around families who then say a comment that they mean well, but lands as criticism, I flood much more easily. So like I'm also thinking about my own body. Like what do I need for my own body that I can't negotiate? And then outside of that is the wants. Like what do I want for the holidays?
当然，我想和兄弟姐妹以及父母一起欢笑、建立联系。我绝对希望有共享脆弱的时刻。这些可能会发生，也可能不会。所以这有助于区分我们的愿望清单——有点像我们的愿望、我们的希望——以及我们的需求。哪些地方是我真正想要把边界和精力放在支持自己建立这些边界上的？哪些是其他事情，更多的是关于我体验到节假日中的那些时刻，
Of course I want to laugh and connect with my siblings and with my parents. And I definitely want there to be moments of shared vulnerability. Those might happen, they might not. So helping differentiate between like our wish list, kind of like our wants, our hopes, and then our needs. Like where are the places that I really want to prioritize the boundaries and my energy around supporting myself with those boundaries? And what are the other things that are more about me experiencing the, you know,
我们在那些时刻感到失望，因为我们对事情可能的样子抱有很高的期望或很大的希望，而结果可能看起来有点不同。这些就是想要的。比如，我真的想在圣诞节早晨和某某人进行一次走心的、有意义的对话吗？也许想，也许今年没发生，但也许明年会。所以，这有助于我区分到底该把精力投入到哪里。我很喜欢为你的家庭圣诞节或家庭节日列一个愿望清单的想法。我的另一招是，我带着非常低的期望去。
those moments in the holidays where we have that feeling, of disappointment because we had high expectations or high hopes for what it might look like, and maybe it looks a little bit differently. And those are kind of the wants. Like, did I want to have this really heart-to-heart meaningful conversation with so-and-so on Christmas morning? Maybe, and maybe it didn't happen this year, but maybe it'll be another year. So that's, that helps me differentiate between what to really put my energy behind. I love the idea of having like a wish list for your family Christmas or your family holiday. my other thing is that I go in with really low expectations.
非常低的期望。而且我也确保自己有，首先，我知道我不想和家人谈论什么。当我回到家时。实际上，我知道这听起来很简单，但我真的会说：我不谈这个。请吧，谢谢。我不打算和你们谈论那个。如果我们非要谈，那我就要走了，抱歉，再见。我是说，我要走了。所以，要么你拥有我的陪伴，要么你得到你对这个问题的答案。
Really low expectations. And I also make sure that I have, firstly, I know what I don't want to talk about with my family, but I'm back home. And I actually, I know it sounds like, it's so simple, but I really do say, like, I'm not talking about this. Please and thank you. Like, I'm not going to talk about that with you. And if we do like I'm going to leave, sorry, bye. Like I'm not, I'm going to leave. So you can either have my company or you can have your answer to this question.
你更想要哪一个？我做的另一件事是给自己留一条出路。我有一个大家庭。是的，大家庭。这是一个庞大而复杂的情况。所以我也知道我需要有自己的时间和空间来远离它。否则我会直接原地爆炸。我们稍微休息一下，休息之后我想谈谈我们如何沟通
Which one would you like more? And the other thing I do is I have like a little bit of an escape. I have a huge family. And yeah, huge family. It's big, complicated situation. So I also know that I need like my own time and space to get away from it. Otherwise I will literally explode. We're going to take a little bit of a break that I want to talk about how we can communicate
父母或家人过去让我们失望的方式。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例只有这么点。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。
the ways in which our parents or our family have disappointed us in the past after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿那些在健康产业中占据主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌失措的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加百分号，在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMAs上拍了两次小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
并试着理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。包括最近一期马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代瘾品的节目。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为瘾品。我随时准备聊聊瘾品，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论瘾品的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里面有某种贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以……
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so...
谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。但我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·1伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。
We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
绝对是的。这是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们一起就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中惊人的不一致之处。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吧？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·奥斯派和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg O'Spy and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
这引发了一场长达数年的法律诉讼来证明真相。你在这起欧文斯案中两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·奥斯派和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Alrighty, we are back with Gwen. So this is a complicated question that I get asked a lot. How do you ring up the times in which? which your family has disappointed you in the past or hurt you, is it worth even bringing it up in your 20s? Or should you just not say anything and just go on and build your own life
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 Iheart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。好了，我们欢迎 Gwen 回来。这是一个我经常被问到的复杂问题。你该如何盘点过去家人让你失望或伤害你的那些时刻？在二三十岁的时候，把这些翻出来真的值得吗？还是说你干脆什么都别说，继续往前走，去建立你自己的生活，
and know that you can't heal what's been broken in them? Well, basically, what is the best alternative to navigating a past situation that you feel is still holding weight for you where you feel you want to say something about it? Yeah. it's, you know, what you're talking about is like how to have a, what I'm hearing in the question is how to have a repair conversation. Like I think that there's, when people are saying they want to share, there's a hope, there's a hope that they'll feel seen and that there will be a feeling of accountability or of empathy for what you experienced. So whenever there's a repair conversation, the first question is, you know, kind of like are both sides ready? And I think what's really challenging is sometimes you're ready for that conversation.
并明白你无法治愈他们身上已经破碎的东西？那么，基本上，对于一个你觉得仍然承载着沉重分量、并且你想说点什么的过去处境，最好的替代解决方法是什么？是的。你所谈论的是，我从问题中听到的是，如何进行一次修复性的对话。我觉得，当人们说他们想要分享时，其实怀有一种期望，期望自己能被看见，期望对方能对自己所经历的事情产生责任感或同理心。因此，每当进行修复性对话时，第一个问题往往是，双方都准备好了吗？我认为真正具有挑战性的是，有时你已经为那场对话做好了准备。
And whether it's a parent or a sibling, they might not be ready for many reasons, right? It might not be, they might be going through something really stressful in their life. just not be in the right mindset. And so sometimes the first question is, how can I tolerate my readiness while the other person isn't yet ready? And so if that's the case, and I rarely think, it rarely works when that type of conversation is forced, you know, when it's like, I need to have it, so we're having this conversation. When there's that feeling of it's happening now, people come in defensive and that feeling of being seen, it's just there's a lower chance. Let's put it that way.
而无论是父母还是兄弟姐妹，他们可能出于各种原因还没有准备好，对吧？可能不是时候，他们生活中可能正经历着非常压力重重的事情，或者只是不在正确的心态中。所以有时候第一个问题是：当对方还没准备好时，我该如何容忍自己的这份准备就绪？如果情况是这样的话，而且我很少认为——当这种对话被强求时，很少能奏效，你知道的，比如“我需要谈，所以我们现在就得谈”。当有那种“事情正在发生”的感觉时，人们会带有防御心理，而那种被看见的感觉成功的几率就会降低。我们这么说吧。
There's a lower chance of not happening. So if the other person, oh, did I cut you off? No, no, we didn't. Okay. If the other person isn't ready, then the question is, how can I have this conversation, you know, in therapy or with people who are going to listen? for some clients I've done, you know, writing letters, letters to themselves, writing letters to their past selves, different, like, creative expressions, that it's not the same thing, but it helps them tolerate that difference,
没能发生的几率更高。所以如果对方——哦，我是不是打断你了？没有，没有。好吧。如果对方还没准备好，那么问题就是，我该如何在治疗中，或者与那些愿意倾听的人进行这场对话？对于一些来客，我做过的是，你知道的，写信，写给自己，写给过去的自己，通过各种不同的创意表达——这虽然不是一回事，但它能帮助他们容忍那种差异，
that, like, that waiting period of this other person isn't ready yet. And also tolerate the fact that there's no guarantee, you know, the other person might not ever be ready. There are some parents who say, you know, the past is a past, is a past, I don't want to go back there, right? And so that's, unfortunately, that that's part of relationships is that we, we only have control over us naming what we're wanting and what we're needing, and we can't always control the other person wanting to engage. But if you have a sense, you know, that they're naming things like, I want to deepen my relationship with you, or
也就是对方还没准备好的那种等待期。并且还要容忍这样一个事实：没有任何保证，你知道的，对方可能永远都不会准备好。有些父母会说，“过去就是过去，过去的事情就让它过去吧，我不想再回到那个时候了”，对吧？所以不幸的是，这就是人际关系的一部分：我们只能控制自己去说出我们想要什么、我们需要什么，而我们并不总能控制对方是否愿意参与。但是，如果你感觉到他们表达了诸如“我想深化我们之间的关系”之类的话，或者
you're feeling really distant, like I'm wanting to kind of form our adult, our adult relationship of a parent-child relationship. Then starting by just naming, you know, kind of your intention for the conversation. A lot of parents are, avoid conversations like that because there's an anxiety
你觉得关系真的很疏远，比如你想建立我们的成年人关系——一种父母与子女的关系。那么，不妨先从说出你对这次对话的意图开始。许多父母之所以逃避这样的对话，是因为他们对“过去无法改变”这一事实
and there's a pain around the fact that you can't change the past. So if there's an naming of, hey, mom or hey, dad, I want to share my experience because I want to have an authentic connection with you. I want you to know what I went through, and I understand that you can't change the past. I really kind of am just hoping to feel seen and feel heard
感到焦虑和痛苦。因此，如果一开始就明确表达：“嘿，妈妈，或者嘿，爸爸，我想分享我的经历，是因为我想和你建立真正的连接。我希望你知道我经历了什么，我理解你无法改变过去。我其实只是希望能被拥有过这段经历的人看见并听到”，
by the person that I had this experience with. That can kind of create a foundation for a deeper empathetic conversation, like maybe more success. There also are a lot of people who have these conversations in therapy. I'm more and more there. I'm seeing a couple therapists who are also supporting parent-child's diads.
这可以为更深层次的、富有同情心的对话奠定基础，也许成功的可能性会更大。也有很多人是在心理治疗中进行这些对话的。我越来越经常看到这种情况。我看到一些夫妻治疗师也在支持父母与子女的双人组合。
So like holding the space of a two-person conversation with adult children because a lot of adult children have stuff they want to talk about. And a lot of parents are feeling a little confused and sometimes bewildered that they don't understand why this energy is coming from their adult child and they want support figuring it out. So there are.
就像为成年子女与父母之间的双人对话提供一个安全的空间一样，因为许多成年子女有他们想谈的事情。许多父母则感到有些困惑，甚至有点不知所措，他们不明白为什么成年子女会带有这种情绪，他们需要支持来弄清楚这一点。因此，
lots of different spaces for these types of conversations. But I would say, yeah, like, naming your intention. And then knowing that, like, your parent might be quite surprised. They might be kind of a little caught off guard. And it might be multiple iterations of this type of conversation. I will share from my personal experience that I had conversations like this with my dad when I was in my 20s. And that he was, he was the breadwinner, he was working a lot. There was four kids in a family. So some of the things that I wished he had understood was what it was like to have a parent who was contributing a ton but not physically or very emotionally present and how there was that feeling of loss around that.
这类对话有许多不同的空间。但我会说，是的，比如明确你的意图。然后你要知道，你的父母可能会感到非常惊讶。他们可能会觉得有点措手不及。而且这种类型的对话可能需要进行多次迭代。我愿分享我的个人经历：我在二十多岁时曾与我父亲有过这样的对话。他是家里的顶梁柱，工作非常忙。家里有四个孩子。所以我希望他能理解的一些事情是，有一个奉献巨大但在物理上或情感上却很不活跃的父母是怎样的感受，以及围绕这种感受所带来的失落感。
And every time I tried in my 20s to express this, it came off critical. He was kind of like WTF. Like, I, like, you know, provided, I gave you so much. Yeah, I tried my best. Like, oh. And it never, it just created more disconnection. And then during the pandemic, it's being forced to be on Zoom. We started having, like, Zoom chats where it was finally the right time and place for us to have that conversation. And it was really, really beautiful.
每当我二三十岁时试图表达这一点时，听起来都像是在批评。他有点像是一脸懵（WTF）。就好像：“我，你知道的，付出了那么多，我供养了你。是的，我尽力了。哦。”这从来没有起过好作用，反而造成了更多的疏离。后来在疫情期间，由于被迫通过 Zoom 交流，我们开始进行诸如 Zoom 聊天这样的交流，那终于成了我们进行那场对话的正确时间和地点。那真的是非常非常美好。
You know, he shared authentically and tearfully about what it was like to be on client. calls while he was hearing me and my sister be sung happy birthday and blow out of birthday candles and he was being pulled in and had to miss that and I shared authentically about how it really felt like my focus was on my mom and I didn't have a focus on my dad and how that lack of connection like I didn't feel connected to him and that was like really weird to just be connecting in my adult life with him and um I and I don't know. We both leaned into it with a lot of honesty and authenticity, and it was clumsy, but now I can really say, like, we're building something new that I never thought would happen. It's quite,
你知道的，他真实而泪流满面地分享了当他在听我和我妹妹唱生日歌、吹生日蜡烛时，自己却在接客户电话的感受，他被拉扯着却不得不错过那些。而我也真实地分享了，我的注意力似乎全放在了我妈妈身上，而没有放在我爸爸身上，以及那种缺乏连接感——我感觉不到与他的连接，并且在成年后与他建立连接觉得真的很奇怪。而且，嗯，我不知道。我们都带着极大的诚实和真实投入其中，虽然过程有些笨拙，但现在我真的可以说，我们正在建立一些我从未想过会发生的事情。这相当奇妙，
it just has its own beauty and it's a new chapter. So it took us a lot of time to get to that. And I guess that's what I want to normalize is that sometimes it's both people have to live more life until conversations can happen that go the way you want. I really, I think that's a really beautiful reminder. You have to live more life before you can have the conversations you want to have. And I really appreciate that you said at the beginning, you can't have this conversation, this repair conversation unless both people are ready. And I guess also unless you know what you want to get out of it, right?
它有它独特的美好，也是一个新的篇章。所以我们花了很长时间才走到这一步。我想我想让大家习以为常的一点是，有时需要双方都经历更多的人生，对话才能朝着你期望的方向发展。我真的觉得这是一个非常美好的提醒。在能够进行你想要的对话之前，你必须经历更多的人生。而且我非常感激你在开始时说过的一句话：除非双方都准备好了，否则你无法进行这场对话，这场修复性的对话。我想，除非你知道自己想从中得到什么，对吧？
because sometimes if you go to a parent and you're like, all I want is an apology, you might not get that. And so if that's, I think going into a repair conversation, you have to want something that you'd be okay with them not being able to give you in a way. So you have to be okay with them, maybe not apologizing,
因为有时如果你去找父母，心里想着“我想要的只是一句道歉”，你可能根本得不到。因此，如果那是你的目的，我认为在进入一场修复性对话时，你所追求的东西必须是即便他们无法给予你，你也能接受的。所以你必须能够接受他们或许不会道歉，
maybe not being able to say, yeah, I totally messed up there. Because I think maybe 90% of the time, a parent isn't going to say, yeah, I messed up. because that's not how like human ego works.
或许无法说出“是的，我在那件事上彻底搞砸了”。因为我认为，可能 90% 的情况下，父母是不会说“是的，我搞砸了”的，因为人类的自我（Ego）不是那样运作的。
And for, you know, being a parent is sometimes the biggest thing that anyone's done in their life. I think it's the biggest thing that most people do in their life, raising a child, raising a family. And so, you know, they don't want to acknowledge that they were maybe a failure at that thing, even though you're sitting across with them saying, like, this hurt me, this was painful. All I want from you is to acknowledge it. Giving that up means giving up a sense of accomplishment for them and a sense of pride as well. I also think that when you talk about both people need to be ready, I think about emotionally immature parents for whom that's never going to happen.
而且对于——你知道的，成为父母有时是某人一生中做过的最大的一件事。我认为这是大多数人在其一生中做的最大的一件事，那就是抚养孩子、建立家庭。所以，你知道的，他们不想承认自己在做这件事上可能是一个失败者，尽管你正坐在他们对面说“这伤害了我，这很痛苦。我从你这里得到的全部要求就是承认它”。放弃这一点，意味着放弃他们的一种成就感以及自豪感。我还认为，当你谈到双方都需要准备好时，我想到了那些情感上不成熟的父母，对于他们来说，这种对话永远不会发生。
There is never going to be an acknowledgement from them. They're probably never going to be ready. I've seen it so many times with people who, you know, parents have passed. away and they've never had the conversations. So I like that you've offered this alternative if there is a way to give yourself closure. There is a way to take everything that you've experienced and not need the acknowledgement of the person who's perhaps caused it. You just need to acknowledge it yourself and find a way to make it part of your story, but not the defining part. So how do you think that we can find closure ourselves if we maybe aren't speaking to our families if we have
他们永远不会给予承认。他们可能永远都不会准备好。我见过太多次这种情况了：父母已经离世，而人们却从未有过这样的对话。所以我很喜欢你提供的这种替代方案，即如果有一种方法可以让自己获得内心的释怀。有一种方法可以吸收你所经历的一切，而不需要那个可能导致这一切的人的承认。你只需要自己去承认它，并找到一种方法让它成为你故事的一部分，而不是决定性的部分。那么，如果我们可能不和家人说话，如果我们有
emotionally immature parents if a parent has passed away and the effects are still there how can we bring about closure when it comes to complicated family dynamics for ourselves yeah yeah I mean I yeah it's such a good question I'll just to um you name the with the dynamic of emotionally immature parents, I like to think about like there's some parents who, as you're saying, like just aren't interested in in that level of growth. And there's also some parents who want it, but are in their own process, like it just catching up. Like they're playing like way catch up, you know, so kind of like differentiating between parents who aren't interested in authentic, vulnerable relationships where there's a safety to be
情感不成熟的父母，或者如果父母已经离世而影响依然存在，你认为我们该如何为自己带来复杂的家庭动态带来的释怀呢？是的，是的。我的意思是，是的，这是一个太好的问题了。我只想……你提到了情感不成熟父母的动态，我喜欢这样想：有些父母，正如你所说的那样，根本对那种水平的成长不感兴趣。还有一些父母虽然渴望成长，但却处于他们自己的进程中，就像是在艰难地追赶。就像他们是在拼命追赶一样，你知道的。所以，这有点类似于区分那些对真实、脆弱且具有安全感的深度关系不感兴趣的父母，以及
honesty. And the parents who really want that but are just kind of like in kindergarten. Like they're like, they're like playing catch up and they're, you know, it's kind of, if you can hold that, like, wow, they're, they're doing, they're doing the emotional growth that I started when I was in my 20s, but they're starting in their 60s. They're like 70. So I do believe in the human spirit, when the human spirit wants growth, that it can happen at any age. But as you said, there are some people who just aren't interested in that shift. And that's their choice, right? So to your question, you know, I find that I really, really believe in the power of healing in relationship. and it doesn't always happen in, it doesn't always happen,
诚实。那些真正想要做到这一点的父母，可能刚开始就像在幼儿园一样。他们就像是在追赶进度，你知道的，如果你能接受这一点，就会发现：哇，他们正在经历我二十多岁时才开始的情感成长，而他们却在六十多岁才开始，甚至已经七十岁了。所以我真的相信人类的精神，当人类的精神想要成长时，它可以在任何年龄发生。但正如你所说，有些人就是对这种转变不感兴趣，这也是他们的选择，对吧？所以回到你的问题，我发现我非常非常相信人际关系中治愈的力量，而且这并不总是发生在，它并不总是发生在……
the healing that you want to happen with maybe your parent might end up happening in other relationships. So that kind of broadening the view of, you know, when I'm thinking about what was the wound, what was the dynamic that happened between you and your parent? and what was the underlying wound? Maybe it was your parent, you know, telling you how you should think or how you should feel. And so listening for that theme as it's coming up in other relationships,
你希望在父母身上得到的治愈，最终可能会在其他关系中实现。因此，拓宽视野来看待这些问题——当我在思考曾经的创伤是什么，你和父母之间发生了怎样的动态，以及背后的创伤是什么时。也许是你的父母告诉你应该如何思考，或者应该如何感受。所以，去留意当这种主题在其他关系中再次出现时……
maybe with a manager at work or maybe with, you know, a friend or an intimate partner. And seeing what it's like to find your voice, to name your truth and to navigate, you know, that dynamic with someone. where maybe they have a little bit more space to hear you and to see you. So, you know, although, you know, I wouldn't recommend like seeking out, you know, although this happens, like seeking out a, like, a parallel relationship and, you know, kind of enacting, like, enacting what didn't happen with your parents and enacting it in all future romantic relationships, I think when there's a consciousness around it, like, what are your rooms, and when you see those things show up,
也许是与工作中的主管，或者是与朋友、亲密伴侣的关系。看看去寻找自己的声音、说出自己的真相，以及与某人共同应对这种动态是怎样的体验。在那里，对方可能稍微有更多的空间去倾听你、理解你。所以，虽然我不会建议去刻意寻找一段平行关系，去重演那些在父母身上没有发生过的事情，并在所有未来的恋爱关系中不断重复——我认为，当对此有了一种觉察，知道自己的创伤是什么，并且当看到这些情况出现时……
with the right people who want to be holding that space of really understanding where you're coming from, you can have really, really healing moments where they offer correctional experience. Sometimes that happens in therapy. Sometimes that happens in other relationships. But I would say knowing your themes, know your wounds, like know what what needs didn't get met and and listen and notice for one that's showing up.
与那些愿意提供空间、真正理解你背景的合适人选在一起时，你就能拥有非常具有治愈意义的时刻，他们能提供纠正性的体验。有时这发生在治疗中，有时发生在其他关系中。但我想说的是，了解你的主题，了解你的创伤，了解有哪些需求没有得到满足，去倾听并留意它们何时出现。
I do really believe that there's a way that you talked about like the life cycle of an emotion. There's a there's a life cycle of stories that like things come back up. And when they come up, we have an opportunity to give ourselves the space and the power or the compassion or the backbone or the softness that we wish we had experienced in the past. there's this beautiful phrase that I love, which is wherever you go, there you are. And so I think it's the same with relationships. You know, whatever happened in past relationships that didn't get to be fully resolved or fully metabolized, it's going to show up again. And this time you might have a little more wisdom, a little more tolerance, and the person might have a little bit more space
我真的相信，正如你之前谈到的情感生命周期那样，故事也有其生命周期，事情会再次浮现。当它们浮现时，我们有机会给自己空间和力量，或者给予自己那些曾希望在过去得到的同情、骨气或温柔。有一句我非常喜欢的优美名言：无论你走到哪里，你就在哪里。所以我觉得人际关系也是如此。过去关系中那些未能得到完全解决或充分代谢的事情，将会再次出现。而这一次，你可能会多了一点智慧、多了一点包容，而对方也可能会有更多的空间……
for that experience to unfold in a very different way. So, yeah, I'd say have faith in what it looks like to continue to practice authentic, vulnerable relationships for yourself and with others. Even if you can't do that with your family. Like you said, you can do that with friends, you can do that with mentors, you can do that with partners, boyfriends, girlfriends. One of the big things for me that I think is so healing, if you can't have those, those conversations and that closure really with family is being able to say,
让这种体验以一种截然不同的方式展开。所以，是的，我会说，对继续为自己和他人练习真实、脆弱的关系保持信念。即使你无法与家人做到这一点。正如你所说，你可以与朋友、导师、伴侣、男朋友、女朋友做到这一点。对我来说，如果无法真正与家人进行那些对话和获得真正的闭环，那么其中一件非常治愈的大事就是能够说……
well, that's not going to be passed on. That's not going to be how their relationships work. No one is hopefully going to come to them at 60 and say, you know, you caused me this hurt, you cause me this pain. There is a lot of closure, I think, in healing yourself and in breaking the generational chain. and saying all that work that they were maybe unable to do, I have now done it. And so it's kind of like cutting off the head of a disease, right? If perhaps, you know, whatever it was that has been passed down through your lineage,
嗯，这一切不会再传下去了。人际关系不应该是这样的。希望以后不会有人在60岁时对他们说：你知道吗，你给我带来了这样的伤害，带来了这样的痛苦。我认为，治愈自己并斩断代际链条，本身就具有很大的闭环意义。告诉自己，他们可能无法完成的所有那些工作，我已经完成了。这就像斩断一种疾病的根源一样，对吧？如果说，曾经通过你的家族血脉传递下来的某种东西……
because often the way that your parents or your family has interacted with you as the way that their family's interacted with them, even if you don't have children, right, knowing that your relationships, you know, your personal relationships won't have this dynamic. The relationships you have with nieces and nephews won't have this dynamic. The relationship that you have with your partner won't reflect that that maybe your parents had in their marriage. That is an incredibly healing thing. So I have one more question to ask you. And it doesn't even have to do with family.
因为通常你的父母或家人与你互动的方式，就是他们的家人与他们互动的方式。即使你没有孩子，也要知道，你的个人关系将不再具有这种动态。你与侄子侄女的关系将不再具有这种动态。你与伴侣的关系也将不再反映出你父母在婚姻中可能存在的那些问题。这是一件极其治愈的事情。所以，我还有一个问题要问你，这甚至与家庭无关。
It's just something we ask every single guest, which is if you had one piece of advice, a bullet point piece of advice for someone in their 20s, what would it be? Like take it one step at a time. You know, one day at a time, even with what you were naming about the not wanting to repeat generational trauma, like, we each make one change, like small changes in the patterns of the families that we are born into. And future generations, whether those are relationships or our own biological or raised children, future generations are going to make little shifts that we don't have to do it. all, but we can be proud of what we are doing. So, yeah.
这只是我们向每一位嘉宾都会提的一个问题：如果你能给二十多几岁的人一条建议、一个要点式的建议，那会是什么？就像是一步一个脚印。你知道的，过好每一天，甚至就像你刚才提到的不想重复代际创伤一样——我们每个人做出一个改变，在我们出生的家庭模式中做出微小的改变。未来的世代，无论是人际关系、我们自己的亲生孩子还是抚养的孩子，未来的世代都会做出微小的转变，我们不必把所有事情都做完，但我们可以为自己正在做的事情感到自豪。所以，是的。
Little changes. I like that. That's a beautiful piece of advice to end things with. Gwen, I want to thank you so much for coming on to talk about a pretty deep, meaningful, vulnerable conversation and a vulnerable topic. Where can the listeners find you? How can they learn more about your work? Yeah.
微小的改变。我喜欢这个。这是一个用来作为访谈结束的绝佳建议。格温，非常感谢你来和我们谈论这个非常深刻、有意义且脆弱的对话和话题。听众在哪里可以找到你？他们如何能更多地了解你的工作？是的。
Well, my website is www.gwendolyn Watson.com. and I'm on LinkedIn posting about mental health, parenting, emotions, all the stuff that we think doesn't get discussed in corporate environments. I'm doing it on LinkedIn. So feel free to connect with me there and, yeah, continue the conversation. Yeah, everything will be linked in the episode description as always. And I just want to thank you guys for listening to this episode. If this is something that you're really dealing with this holiday period. Oh my goodness, you are not alone. You are not alone. And there are so many amazing resources out there as well that I'll also leave in the episode description. Make sure that you are following along and that you give the show
好的，我的网站是 www.gwendolynWatson.com。我在 LinkedIn 上发布关于心理健康、育儿、情感以及所有我们认为在职场环境中不会被讨论的事情。我都在 LinkedIn 上分享。所以请随时在那里与我联系，并且，是的，继续这个对话。是的，所有链接都会像往常一样放在本期节目的简介中。我只想感谢大家收听本期节目。如果这正是你在这个假期期间正在真正面对的事情，哦天哪，你并不孤单。你并不孤单。而且还有很多非常棒的资源，我也会把它们留在本期节目的简介中。请确保关注我们，并给节目一个……
a five-star review wherever you are listening. You can also continue the conversation. If you have thoughts, feelings about this episode, you can DM me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. And we're always taking further episode suggestions. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle to yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled,
五星好评，无论你在哪里收听。你也可以继续参与对话。如果你对本期节目有任何想法或感受，你可以在 Instagram 上私信我：That Psychology Podcast。我们随时接受更多的节目建议。但直到下期节目之前，请保持安全。善待自己，温柔对待自己，我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧精神、健身以及在这个奇特的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端变得更快乐、更充实……
healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字是数字的 2%，可在 IHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看过去》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个大时刻。
84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起，弄清楚我们是如何撑过那段日子的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild. It was a wild. year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代那样。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and hosts Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men
嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难中学习》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行其他任何地方都不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人……
carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played and just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
穿着铠甲？这向世界发出了一个信号：你是不好惹的，但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难中学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑彻底短路了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证是由真人制作。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。